( intro music )
I went to Tanzania
and I went to an area
in Tanzania near Lake Eyasi,
where there's Hadza people.
It is the oldest
diet remaining on Earth.
And the Hadza
are about 1,300-1,500
and out of these 1,500 there's
300 that are living a real...
last full-time
hunter-gatherer,
full-time meaning there's
no back-up option.
There's no little bit of
agriculture-planting whatever.
There's no herding
of something.
They live strictly off
hunting and gathering food.
Africa is,
you know, difficult.
You need to
coordinate everything.
I was going really
deep in the bush
I need to have all the food
with me, all the water with me.
And then I meet with the Hadza.
And in front of me
these guys show up.
( audience laughter )
Band of brothers,
you know, they are like "wow"
So they are 100 percent
hunter-gatherer
and they go
around every day
looking for food every morning.
This guy is like this... what
they like most is honey.
They gather a lot of it.
And to get honey they
make fire first.
They don't have
light or matches,
they don't have
this stuff.
They live really
self-sufficiently
in the bush, at
least these guys.
Some other guys, you know
there's other areas of Hadza
land where there is
more touristy area but
these guys were
really the real deal.
They make fire, then
they smoke the beehive
and then they get
the honey in it.
Some time there is a bird
called the Honeyguide.
that would bring them to
the honey, to the beehive.
And then they-- everybody
is really excited.
They don't store stuff.
They get too excited.
They get bitten,
they get stung.
I got stung too.
These are killer bees so
bit scary, you know...
Honey is incredible.
It's like the power-bar,
the ultimate power-bar.
There's so much energy in this.
And on top of it
they often eat it
like this
straight with larva.
You can see the little white
spot, these are larva.
So you get this sweet and
sour mixture in your mouth.
It's just-- you feel like
wow, this is so powerful.
There's protein and there
is this incredible
amount of energy
coming into you.
They share it with
the women there.
They sometime put
some on the side
to bring to the
elderly that's
their camp or their
real babies.
But they eat everything on the
spot more or less otherwise.
One thing I have to tell you
right about the Hadza is
they smoke a lot of marijuana.
( audience laughter )
And so they trade this stuff
and this is after they smoke.
( Hadza man coughing )
( Hadza boys coughing )
( audience laughter )
This goes on for five minutes,
I had to cut it short.
But then this goes
on like this.
( audience laughter )
So, they do that,
you know, they
are really living
in the moment
it doesn't matter, you
know, it's just "whoo".
It's difficult for me
to coordinate things.
Can we do that in ten minutes?
"Ah, yeah, it's alright man.
Take it easy, yo!"
( audience laughter )
I had to kind of Zen-out.
So, now you know in
what state they
are when I am
photographing them.
Just so you know.
That's Mokoa and
his wife Wande.
And in the morning
Mokoa goes hunting
and Wande goes foraging.
Often the woman
looks for tubers.
There's this vine
coming out of
the trees, they
locate them, dig
they find the root, they cut
out the root with a knife
and they keep the
root, and then
it's a little bit
like potato.
When they move around
and they pass something edible
they will just grab food.
And some time they
are looking straight
but they see food on the
corner of their eye,
and they just go like this.
It's quite amazing.
They just keep in movement but
eating, feeding themselves.
This is "Kongolobe", it's a
special berry that grows there.
And then they go back
to the watering hole
drink up and go back to camp.
Camp is these
beautiful houses
that are like
upside down nests.
The women always do them.
Inside, you know, it's
quite beautiful at night.
This woman was cooking stork .
And outside the men are
yapping and yapping
like they always do
everywhere, anywhere.
( audience laughter )
And they are telling
hunting stories.
( speaking in Hadza )
( bees buzzing )
( birds chirping )
( speaking in Hadza )
Matthieu: Mokoa goes in the
morning hunting
and I follow him around.
They take all different
kind of arrows.
There's the arrow for
the bird, there's
the poison arrow for
the big animals,
there's the other one, you
know, for medium animals.
And then there is
the one on the right
to finish up
a wounded animal.
They walk for hours, it's very
hard, it's very exhausting .
Some time they only get
these tiny little birds.
They don't get many animals.
It's quite rare.
There are animals but, you know
they are used to being hunted
for thousands and
thousands of years and they
hear you coming from so
far away and I
was with them.
And you know, so it was
even extra challenging.
The ancestors of the Hadza
have been living in Hadza
land for about 40,000 years.
That's what
anthropology tells us.
It's incredible, they have left
no impact on their environment.
So they go around
with bow and arrows.
They often miss their target.
This is Kampala.
He had missed a...
just a bird there.
And whenever there's a
higher viewpoint like this
they climb up on top of
trees to look for wildlife.
They usually get up
early morning and
hunt until noon or
something like that.
Below trees
they make these blinds
to hunt from blinds.
They some time, they
get stork, this
migratory bird that
comes from Europe .
The hunting process
is very meditative.
You know, you're
getting really into
the rhythm because
nobody talks.
They talk very quietly and
you walk and you walk.
It's very beautiful.
It's not like
hunting with rifle
because the bow don't make any
noises when they're hunting.
But then when they see animals
it becomes very hectic
and they start running around.
They eat everything
they can find
except snake and elephants.
Elephants, the arrow can't
go through their skins
and snake, they're
just scared of them.
This is a little baby
bush that they got that day.
And then they, you know,
have a smoke break.
- Quiet reflection .
- ( audience laughter )
I couldn't believe it.
I was like, "oh, unbelievable".
They roll in newspaper,
there's no...
You know, they get
newspaper and
they roll straight
in there.
And then, you know,
it doesn't matter
right after that
they are running around
they're incredibly flat.
When they run they
have their upper
body that is kind
of-- back like this.
It's quite impressive to
see them running.
And then get dik-dik
like this .
This is the smallest gazelle
can be found in Africa.
And then Mokoa's like we'll get
up to a higher point of view.
He will point and see,
something there and it was
really intense.
And we run there, and you know,
two hours, three hours later,
after much tracking and stuff
they get this vervet monkey
that fell off that tree.
It was very powerful.
I love my time with the Hadza.
You know, they know how to
strike a pose too
- and play dumb .
- ( audience laughter )
This is Mokoa.
And you know, this
is a left camp.
This is what they leave behind.
This stack of branches,
the grass has fallen off,
this is all that's left.
Think about that.
They have lived for
40,000 years
in that area and
there's no tracks.
You know, there's nothing
left behind from their times .
The thing with their story
that really strike me is that
wherever you eat local and you
spend energy to get your food
you are for the better.
And this would be
the message that
I want to hope and
give to that...
through that, you know
through my experience living
with these people in all this.
If you can do
anything to enforce
yourself to grow something
or if you eat meat, you know,
learn to kill a chicken.
I mean, you know, if
you're going to eat meat
you should learn
once in your life...
I've killed a goat once
since I've seen that
because I eat meat every
day, not every day, you know
but every three days maybe.
And so I think it's important
to understand
where the food comes from.
And to do everything you can
to eat local.
Well, that's my point
through that experiences.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
( applause )